all right thirdly today
this is also big news we have a horrible
supreme court right now that that
shouldn't be news but we do thanks by
the way
to donald trump choosing three people
who are now on it
rather than hillary clinton that
that cannot be ignored that's a reality
but that disastrous supreme court has
put a final stop
to donald trump's demands that white
house records
not be provided to the committee
investigating the trump riots this is
good news
cnbc reporting the supreme court has
rejected a trump request to block the
release of records to the january 6th
committee the supreme court rejected a
request from former president trump to
block those records the ruling which
trump cannot appeal
sets the stage for more than 700 pages
of trump white house records to soon be
sent by the national archives to the
committee that's an important detail it
is not now trump who has to release them
it is the national archives that will
release them trump had argued that he
had the authority as a former president
to invoke executive privilege to prevent
the disclosure of the records president
biden has declined to invoke executive
privilege for the records which the
committee wants as part of its probe of
the invasion of the capital by a mob of
trump supporters this is a very very
good decision and it is the correct
decision
notably
the supreme court order the supreme
court decision
was eight to one the one was justice
clarence thomas
who dissented and said now trump should
be able to block it
and what is particularly disturbing
about that is that clarence thomas's
wife
cheered the stop the steel rally on
january 6th
that ultimately was one of the primary
inciting factors of those trump riots
and she subsequently apologized to her
husband's law clerks but given clarence
thomas's obvious conflict of interest
here if he had respect for the law he
would recuse himself from anything even
remotely related to the january six
trump riots but it is clarence thomas
after all and imagine i mean just think
about that the wife
of a supreme court justice was cheering
cheering cheering
the event
and the individuals
that
led to
an attempted insurrection
at the country in the country where your
husband is a supreme court justice it's
absolutely stunning stuff
but ginny thomas is maybe something to
focus on on a different day that's the
supreme court decision
this appears to be the end i know we say
that all the time with trump and trying
to hide records well this this is it now
and then something else happens by every
reasonable stretch of the imagination
this is a supreme court decision and
this is it
and the records will be provided to the
committee whether they will be made
public
deliberately
or because they will leak or whatever we
do not yet know but that's the supreme
court decision and it is the correct
decision let me know what you think will
we ever see those records you can find
me on twitter at dpakman we're going to
take a very quick break and be right
back
one of our sponsors is all form hands
down the easiest way to custom build
your own sofa you choose the premium
fabric you want you choose the sofa size
shape color even the color of the legs
you can customize every aspect of your
new sofa to make sure it's the perfect
fit for your home i got my first
all-form sofa a year ago i just got a
second one which is really exciting
these really are the sofas i would have
bought for my home even if all form was
not a sponsor you really can't beat the
quality the modern minimal design the
sofas are spill stain and scratch proof
you can buy one piece and start with
that and then buy more seats and
accessories to add on later shipping is
fast and free you get a hundred days to
decide if you want to keep the sofa it
comes with a forever warranty and you'll
get twenty percent off when you go to
all form dot com slash pacman the link
is right underneath this video